talk talk fast you first my name is  Sarah Connor  August 29 1997 supposed to be Judgment  Day  but I changed the future saved three  billion lives  enough of a resume for you know  you may have changed the future  change our fate  you're scared  to protect you  I've never seen one like you before  almost human I am human just enhanced  why do you care what happens to her  because I was her  I can see you're very upset I'm going to  help you protect the girl  else is gonna die because of me  if you don't make it  everybody dies respect a big pain  brother whole body's a weapon  all right  and this is all over I am going to kill  you I understand  I'll be back  you  you